dj obviously the pandemic affected your
life very significantly um you know you
didn't play last season what was it like
and i i presume you did get vaccinated
what was it like emotionally for you
when you got vaccinated
um it was so i wasn't going back and
forth on you know whether to do it or
not but once my and i talked to my
parents and once they got it done i was
like well i mean it's no point for me
not to get it done and obviously i opted
out because of covet so while i come
back and get going i'd just be pretty
silly but
i'm sorry but
once i talked to my parents uh you know
they they had got vaccinated i was like
well i mean i feel like this right thing
to do so i wouldn't got vaccinated as
well
yeah for many people it's a simple logic
if you're concerned about getting covert
you get the vaccine guys opted out last
year because they were concerned about
getting code passing it to family
members so this year you come back and
play there's a vaccine that's available
you get the vaccine you're concerned
about the facility you get the vaccine
the logic seems far simpler than it
ultimately plays out in practice peter
and that's part of what we're going to
talk about you had
a report that that was stunning to me on
monday that one team has managed to get
65 of 90 players vaccinated now six
weeks away from training camp that
that's an impressive number and that's
that suggests that that team will get to
an 85 threshold at which there may be
added benefits for the teams involved
that that may be an outlier though
because i get the impression a lot of
these coaches are quietly frustrated
that their guys aren't choosing to get
vaccinated sooner rather than later
well definitely you heard how frustrated
sean mcdermott of the buffalo bills was
uh because it appears as though they're
going to have a very hard time
getting enough players vaccinated to
live
sort of
2019 lives
and just so that viewers understand what
we're talking about mike right in 2019
pre pandemic everybody was just coming
in and out of business just like they
were all across the united states
everything was normal but in 2020 every
team all players had to be masked uh
there were significant restrictions when
you went on the road
uh to play a game
other than to go to your meeting room
and go and get your to-go meals to eat
in your room
uh there was that you couldn't leave
your hotel
everything was restricted you couldn't
go out during your bye week you were
basically captive you had to stay in
your city and get tested before eight
o'clock every morning
so
now
the prospect is
that if you get and i keep hearing the
number is 85 just like it is in baseball
but if you get 85
of your players
vaccinated which in the nfl i believe is
77 of 90
in uh training camp so
if teams get 77 players
vaccinated then they can go back to
having business as usual
and so that is what coaches really
really want and you want to see
frustrated coaches and i did ask one
coach
about how his team would be different
this year if they had to do it and he
goes hey he goes quite honestly he said
we're going to work very hard to make
this not be the case but i worry about
internal problems with the team with
some players saying
get the bleep in vaccine
you know so that we can go and have
basically kind of normal lives but
here's the biggest issue mike that in my
mind is going to convince
some hesitant players to get the vaccine
i think there's a good chance
that during a team's bye week this year
you know if you play for the new england
patriots and you're from southern
california and you plan to go home in
your bye week you won't be able to go
home
you will have to stay in new england and
go to foxborough by 8 o'clock every
morning of the bye week you won't even
get to sleep in during the bye week and
you'll have to go and get
a test
every day to make sure that when the
team gets back
and resumes practices after that bye
week that you can come back with them
you know in that relative normalcy with
mass and with restrictions
it's one thing when everyone on the team
has to do that every day every day get
the test every day can't go away during
the bye week got to get tested every day
gotta wear the mask everyone's gotta do
it
and then when it's only the ones who
haven't been vaccinated that is
a a silent peer pressure that is going
to i think get some of the players who
are on the fence to go ahead and do it
different people have different reasons
for not doing it they continue to tell
us that the vaccines are safe and
effective and the idea is to get the
american population to 70 percent
vaccination so we can get the hurt
immunity and get on with our lives
completely normally again which would be
great if we can get there
but once these guys understand and peter
i think the eureka moment for plenty of
players will be
wait a minute
during the bye week
i i can go wherever i want to go i don't
have to stay here i don't get tested
every day if nothing else convinces them
i feel like that will
i do too mike we'll see what happens but
it's funny this coach who told me had 65
players
it's not that he was cocky about getting
to 77
but he felt like he was gonna have a
good chance to get to 77 players
and and i think
i mean look
i'm probably being naive about this mic
but i think that there are going to be
quite a few teams
that'll get not only to 77 but once the
season starts that will get to 85
of their final 53-man roster and the one
thing that needs to be clarified i think
by the nfl and nfl pa whenever they come
to
an agreement about this i think
it has to be so
uh a you know let's find out for sure
how big the practice squad is going to
be 14
16 15 12 whatever it is
but
although i'm assuming that those players
are going to be a part of it so it's not
necessarily going to be 85 percent of 53
players
it's going to be 85 percent let's say of
67
players
so i think those are big questions that
you don't need to get answered before
the season starts
well it's 57 players who would need to
be vaccinated if you have 67 in the pool
it's 45 if you look at the 53-man roster
and that's an important point because
and
technically
whether or not a player is vaccinated
is not a permissible factor for deciding
whether or not he gets released when
they cut from 90 to 53. technically
they're not allowed to do it and you
can't say the quiet thing out loud like
bill's gm brandon bean did he found out
directly from the nfl you can't say that
but peter
let's not be naive about this reality
when the time comes to put all the names
out there and you decide who you're
keeping and who you're staying and i saw
somebody suggest on twitter also the
bills are going to cut josh allen no if
he doesn't get vaccinated he's safe it's
the guys in those last 10 spots
if you're vaccinated you're more likely
to stay if you're not you're more likely
to be gone if you're a bubble guy it is
going to be a factor that helps you if
you've been vaccinated and it's going to
be a factor that hurts you if you
haven't been no one has to say it
they need to be careful not to have a
bunch of emails or any other text
messages that would reveal that oh we
gotta get rid of this guy he's not
vaccinated but they have they're gonna
know who is and isn't vaccinated this
isn't some secret information
and so i i and i don't think the union's
gonna push them on this either because
the union understands at the highest
levels the value of vaccinations
guys who were not vaccinated who are
fringe players peter i think are going
to be cut
uh i think it's they have a better
chance of being cut than guys who are
being who who have been vaccinated all
things
all things equal all things equal yes
all things two guys all the time
one guy's vaccinated one's not the guy
who's vaccinated stays the guy who isn't
goes that's what's gonna happen even
though they're not supposed to make that
a factor
and and look
who who could blame anybody in the nfl
for doing this you want to get back to
normal you want your team to have some
freedom you want your players to have
some freedom
and
what better way to do this than to get
85 of your players vaccinated
and get back to some semblance of 2019.
now
you know you talk about the josh allen
example you're absolutely right no
really good player is getting cut
because he isn't vaccinated
but that's what i said a minute ago mike
there are going to be some things going
on if some team
is two players away from that 85 percent
limit
you don't think there's going to be some
tacit and maybe some overt
pressure
on the unvaccinated players to stop
bleeping this up for the rest of us
i i mean that also is going to be a
factor i believe in some teams and you
know you're hearing it now i've read a
lot about different baseball teams
where you know the chicago cubs the
general manager is incredibly frustrated
he never thought that being a general
manager is going to require him to plead
with players please
take this vaccine
which can help you prevent
getting a very serious disease
but that's what they have done so i mean
we're going to see that happen in the
nfl we don't know the stories yet but it
will happen
and let me just add this point and i am
joking when i say it but i can't resist
it the hazing ritual of tying a guy to
the goal post this year when they tie
the guy to the goal post hey go ahead
and vaccinate him while we have him
immobilized that that may happen it's
not going to happen but i'm just
that is going to be a real locker room
dynamic you get a leader in the locker
room who has been vaccinated and wants
to have the benefit of the 85 threshold
and wants to be normal and he's a
dynamic strong leader
you i can guarantee you that team's
getting 85 and that's going to be part
of it as well
i i was fascinated by something that
happened yesterday jordan poyer bill's
defensive back was asked about whether
or not he's been vaccinated and we may
hear more of what poyer had to say
yesterday let's let's hear how he
responded to questions about whether or
not he has gotten her will get the
vaccine
real quick before we start i'm not going
to be answering any questions about the
vaccine so
uh you guys can direct your questions
all to football i would love to answer
them so
all respectfully i appreciate it the nfl
put out
um numbers that teams need to reach
certain levels of vaccinations and
there's that word if you reach those
levels you would be able to go to saint
john fisher and actually have
a return on normalcy um
in in some sense do you foresee that
happening john i appreciate you and and
and you know you we've you've done
interviews with me a long time dude but
i'm i'm just not answering any questions
i have anything to do with the vaccine
and right i i i i understand i don't
even want to you know i don't even want
to put that in the in the you know you
know i like camp at st john fisher i
like camp here they're two totally
different um places camp here you get
all the facility you know camp there
obviously you get the um the camaraderie
with the guys staying but you know at
the end of the day that's not my
decision to make um and so you know i'm
just i'm just here with my team right
now but like i said john you know it's
all respect but that's that's how i'm
gonna answer that
you know it's clear from poyer's
comments that he
i would surmise hasn't gotten vaccinated
doesn't intend to get vaccinated why
would you not want to talk about it if
you have been and you support it so
i i think we can infer that that he he's
in the camp where
number one i haven't gotten at number
two i ain't getting it and number three
i ain't talking about it and you know
peter i saw some reaction on social
media to the story we posted about his
comments and and of course social media
it is what it is and what it is at times
is not good but the attitude is well
that this is a medical thing and it's
hipaa and it's private look this is a
this is part and parcel of a football
team because of that 85 threshold
because of the the less
restriction that's going to apply to the
guys who have been vaccinated it becomes
an integral part of your 2021 football
experience this isn't about the science
of vaccinations the philosophy of
vaccinations this is about checking
boxes and getting a team back to normal
plain and simple
and
you know
one of the things that is going to be
odd for me to think about is
when you have guys that are you know
jordan poyer has been a
tremendous not only player but he's been
a tremendous leader for that uh for that
buffalo defense
and and so we'll see what happens mike i
i'd and i don't know whether jordan
poyots i would infer the same thing as
you but i don't know that i mean i guess
my whole point about all of this is that
i think we're in a divided time in our
country
and we have the potential
to have potentially a divided time
among teams this year
and i fully understand why a lot of
players don't want to talk about it
don't want to address it don't want to
do anything because
for all we know
you know
jerry hughes of the bills and and who
whoever else on the bills the guys who
sharing the same locker room
are ferociously pro-vaccine
and so you know
you don't want to open this can of worms
where it's player versus player on a
team because all that can do is help
tear your team asunder
that's why it's going to be so
interesting to see i mean mike can you
imagine this year just imagine this here
that some team team x is 2 and 12. it's
late in the year and they're still
having all these restrictions
and their team is closed off and all
this
don't you think words is going to start
leaking out of there that this guy is
ticked off at that guy because he's
preventing him from from getting to 85.
i absolutely think that's gonna happen
and and peter the bills are at the
center of this
for now and it's and we're not picking
on the bills they're the ones who have
created the stream of news it started
with josh allen expressing equivocation
about the vaccine brandon bean saying
the quiet thing out loud took it to
another level sean mcdermott complaining
about the difficulties in getting guys
to get vaccinated and you know this may
affect all 32 teams equally or it may
just be there are hot spots here or
there and it can affect the chemistry of
a team it can affect the locker room
dynamic and and and let's say regardless
of whether or not there's a paper trail
that would allow grievances to be filed
against the bills when it's time to cut
the roster to 53.
if guys in the locker room who are good
enough like jordan poyer to be exempt
from being shown the door because they
haven't been vaccinated if they think
that the last 15 spots on the roster
were given to guys who were vaccinated
at the expense of guys who weren't that
that could stir it up even more
you know mike it and you know the one
other thing that you're talking about
right now is that
as you go along during the course of a
season i think it can become a
tremendous competitive advantage
both mentally and potentially physically
for other teams
you know if one team in a division
has only
60 percent of their guys vaccinated and
another team in the division has 90
percent and they got all the freedom
everything is beautiful it's wonderful
and then the other team you're starting
to see
see cracks in the chemistry
i'm just
look
and we're
we don't know what november is going to
bring we simply do not know
but i can just tell you that these are
the possibilities that smart people
in the nfl have thought about smart team
people have thought about and they're
just hopeful of getting to 85 percent
and peter there's a very simple argument
to be made
to
those who are reluctant and i say this
from the perspective of someone who is
willing to give the government the
benefit of the doubt when
the former presidents line up all but
one and tell us it's safe and effective
and there is a push for all of us to get
it for the greater good because it is
safe and effective and because the side
effects and the serious consequences are
very few and very far between so i'm
coming from that perspective
but i would say to a player who's on the
fence
think about everything you would do
everything you would give up for a
chance to win a super bowl
okay go get the shot if getting the shot
improves your team's chances of winning
a super bowl then go get it think of all
the illegal drugs guys have done over
the years to improve their ability to
play to make them better things that
have far worse side effects than a
vaccine if we're going to get into you
know steroids and other peds guys do
that to improve their chances of playing
at a high level and winning a super bowl
so i i think the coaches who can
communicate it the right way are going
to be the ones who see themselves with
65 of 90 on their way to 77 and on their
way to 85 percent when the regular
season rolls around peter
can i just say one last thing about this
mike because everybody is probably
screaming hey talk football but the one
last but it is football but that's the
thing it is football it's an important
factor in how football is going to be
played in 2021
there is no question about it but just
think about this for all the people who
say ah you know if the bucks only have
50 don't worry they'll get over it they
got tom brady the only thing to think
about
is that
most of america
starting in
august september october i would say
most of america is going to be back to
living
fairly normal lives people going back to
school college is reopening all of these
things every you know people going back
to their offices and and stadiums
you know being full or close to being
full
there's going to be one very significant
exception
that the superstars on your team who
choose not to be vaccinated you talk
about do everything you can to win a
super bowl can you imagine you report to
training camp on july 27th let's just
say
and if you don't get the vaccine and
your team isn't at 85 percent just
imagine
that every day for the next six and a
half
months
while all of america is back to normal
everywhere it's back to normal
you are not back to normal
because you got to get up every morning
and at seven o'clock get in your car on
off days bye weeks between training camp
everything every day you've got to go
get a nasal swab
you know and every every day when you
walk into your building you have to have
a mask on nobody else has a mask on but
you've got to wear one because you won't
get the vaccine to me
not getting the vaccine
is
an incredible
commitment
to
whatever the principle is for not
getting the vaccine and it is such a
gigantic commitment that that's why i
feel at the end of the day so many
players are going to say hey
screw this i i don't want to have my
life like it was in 2020. i want to be
free in 2021.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports